herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
indien erlebt zurzeit eine art corona
tsunami welle die das land überrollt
heute ein trauriger höchstwert 3780 tote
an einem tag so viele wie noch nie zuvor
und das land hat inzwischen eine
traurige schallmauer durchbrochen es
gibt registrierte infizierte 220
millionen diese marke ist bereits
überschritten insgesamt beklagt das land
mehr als 200.000 tote
hier dürfte die dunkelziffer die
tatsächliche zahl viel höher sein denn
wir hören berichtet dass menschen zu
hause sterben infizierte auf der straße
sterben die am ende gar nicht gezählt
werden wie steht es um indien
wie können wir helfen wenn menschen
verzweifelt zu krankenhäusern rennen die
aber überfüllt sind keinen sauerstoff
liefern können
manch einer sagt das gesundheitssystem
kollabiert manch einer sagt es ist schon
zusammengebrochen
wie ist die lage genau wir wollen mit
zwei deutschen sprechen die dort sind im
land und alles versuchen was in ihrer
macht steht um den menschen zu helfen
zum einen rede mit andreas bett dem
leiter der mission ärzte ohne grenzen in
indien schönen guten namen zu erreichen
sie in neu delhi schön dass sie zeit
haben und haben es hier einladung und
dann reden wir auch mit tobias vogt von
der organisation german doctors er ist
seit vielen vielen jahren schon in
kalkutta und arbeitet dort an einer
klinik für tuberkulosekranke und kennt
indien sehr sehr sehr gut vielen dank
dass wir auch sie als gesprächspartner
heute haben grüße nach kalkutta ja guten
abend in vielen dank wenn sie fragen
haben an unsere beiden gesprächspartner
dann einfach her damit wir wollen sie
gemeinsam klären ihre fragen beantworten
gemeinsam wollen wir uns aber einen
kurzen film anschauen der die aktuelle
lage in indien kurz zusammenfasst
sie kämpfen um jedes leben in indiens
krankenhäusern aber sie können ihr nur
für die kämpfen die überhaupt noch einen
platz finden
wir sind jetzt rein gekommen weil der
patient vorher gestorben ist deshalb
wurde das bett für meine mutter frei
jetzt bekommt sie sauerstoff
wir sind hier in der abstellkammer dabei
sollte sie auf die intensivstation
die sauerstoffflasche haben wir selbst
mitgebracht wir haben sie auf dem
schwarzmarkt gekauft
desaströs die zustände überall die wucht
der welle ist schlicht zu groß für das
gesundheitssystem indiens regierung
spielt das drama herunter will noch
nicht mal den offensichtlichen
sauerstoffmangel eingestehen zugleich
wird sichtbar welche fatalen fehler
begangen wurden der premierminister
verkündete schon im märz wir hätten den
kampf gewonnen
da hat sich arroganz eingeschlichen
leichten und er versprach sogar in reden
würde jetzt die welt retten mit seiner
impfstoffproduktion tatsächlich ist
jetzt nicht mal für die eigene
bevölkerung genug impfstoff da die
produktion hakt weil rohstoffe fehlen
rufe nach einem landesweiten lockdown
werden lauter durch die regierung
fürchtet die wirtschaftlichen folgen so
werden die schrecklichen zahlen jeden
tag schrecklicher und das ist wohl noch
nicht mal das wahre bild
ich schätze dass 50 prozent der toten
gar nicht offiziell gezählt werden die
regierung zählt nur die aus den
krankenhäusern nicht die idee zu hause
sterben und von freiwilligen heer
gebracht werden die bilder der
überlasteten krematorien stehen für das
ganze grauen sie gehen von indien in die
welt wie eine warnung
andreas bett von ärzte ohne grenzen sie
sind in neu delhi wie erleben sie die
lage dort katastrophal um ehrlich zu
sein
die bilder haben es ja gerade wir sehr
eindrucksvoll belegt es ist schrecklich
unsere mitarbeiter berichten von
menschen die vor den krankenhäusern
sterben die darum bitten und betteln
aufgenommen zu werden aber einfach kein
platz da ist es fehlt an betten überall
es fehlt an gesundheitspersonal
sauerstoff ist ist schrecklich
ich will sie sofort fragen weil eine
kritische frage kommt von einem user
hans jürgen scheld schreibt über
facebook setzen sie bitte einmal die
zahlen ins verhältnis zur einwohnerzahl
wenn ich gesagt habe 3780 ein trauriger
höchstwert an toten heute dann kann man
natürlich sagen bei 1,3 1,4 milliarden
menschen acht das ist ja gar nicht so
viel das ist vielleicht vergleichbar zu
deutschland unser korrespondent hat aber
auch angedeutet dass die dunkelziffer
natürlich riesengroß ist und gar nicht
so viele gezählt werden fragen wir
einfach direkt sie wie schätzen sie das
ein
ich sehe ist als riesengroße humanitäre
katastrophe die gerade stattfindet und
unabhängig davon in welcher relation man
das jetzt natürlich ist die bevölkerung
ihr enorm wie sie schon sagten aber
jeder tote ist eine katastrophe an sich
weil viele tote hätten wahrscheinlich
verhindert werden könnten wenn bank
produktionsverfahren gefolgt wird
wir sehen parallel dazu die bilder
nochmal die sehr nachdenklich stimmen
ein pfarrer der deutschsprachigen
gemeinde in neu delhi beschreibt die
lage auch als drastisch und hat heute
geschrieben
die unsicherheit sei enorm groß nach
meinem gefühl sagt dieser pfarrer stehen
wir kurz vor einer panik wie erleben sie
denn in neu delhi in dieser großen stadt
auch die stimmung unter der bevölkerung
also gar nicht mal unter den infizierten
sondern allgemein
natürlich haben die leute unheimlich
angst und panik ist natürlich in den
gesichtern vieler menschen zu sehen die
hoffnungslos durch die stadt ihren und
krankenhaus zu besuchen die vor den
krankenhäusern stehen und einfach nur
ein bett und eine sauerstoffmaske für
ein sauerstoffgerät für ihre
familienmitglieder suchen es ist sehr
sehr schwierig jetzt sind sehr spät ja
nicht als art direkt auf einer
intensivstation sondern sie sind leiter
der mission ärzte ohne grenzen
wenn sie jetzt auch nicht in der ersten
front sozusagen sind aber sie haben ja
mitarbeiter sie haben ja
legen indische kollegen etc wie ist es
denn bei denen haben sie sozusagen auch
in ihrem team infizierte die dann vor
dem gleichen problem stehen absolut wir
sind teil der gesellschaft hier und
natürlich haben unsere mitarbeiter viele
kranke familienmitglieder wir haben
selber etliche mitarbeiter teilweise
verloren also zeitweise gott sei dank
ist niemand gestorben bis jetzt haben
wir hatten schon große zahlen an
mitarbeiter die oscars sind das macht
natürlich unsere arbeit als solches auch
schwieriger und die angst bei unseren
mitarbeitern ist wahrscheinlich genauso
wie im rest ist es denn so wir hören ja
immer wieder von der indischen variante
des corona virus ist das denn jetzt der
grund dass diese infektionszahlen so
dramatisch hoch gehen dass es so viele
tote gibt ansteckungen et cetera ist es
diese variante oder was sind die gründe
dass es jetzt auf einmal so schlimm wird
weil indien das hören wir nun auch im
fernen deutschland
doch eigentlich erst mal ganz gut über
die erste welle durch die erste welle
gekommen ist die zahlen anfang des
jahres runter gegangen sind und dem
stück haben das ja auch gehört dass der
premier eben lockerungen ermöglicht hat
et cetera und dann dachte man doch in
den sei auf einem guten weg was sind die
gründe jetzt das ist absolut richtig
die zahlen waren sehr gering das hat
wahrscheinlich auch dazu geführt dass
man unmöglich gedacht hat na ja das
schlimmste ist vorbei und hat
wahrscheinlich auch dazu geführt dass
prinzipiell die wahrnehmung oder die
achtsamkeit geringer geworden ist die
menschen haben angefangen weniger die
krone grundregel zu befolgen
präventionsmaßnahmen sind vielleicht
nicht immer so eingehalten worden wie
das der fall sein müsste
es haben nach wie vor große
veranstaltung stattgefunden speziell in
den letzten wochen und monaten beratend
für mit hunderttausenden teilnehmern
religiöse feste mit millionen
teilnehmern das führt natürlich in solch
einer pandemischen lage auch wenn es für
eine zeit lang etwas glücklich aussieht
dazu dass das sehr schnell hoch schießen
kann
ob das in der indischen variante sind
dass ich denke das kann man überhaupt
noch nicht sagen wie sie gesagt hat man
nicht
was wir sehen ist vor allen dingen
dieses nicht adäquate verhalten sowohl
der bevölkerung vielleicht auch der
regierung die vorher vielleicht mehr
restriktionen also sie würden sagen das
ist ein fragezeichen ob es jetzt an der
variante liegt aber wenn man
wahlkampfveranstaltungen macht wenn man
glaubt corona sei sozusagen gegessen
oder überstanden und sie sagen religiöse
feste dann ist das die eine ist nicht
genügend vorsorge bereitet worden
getroffen worden für eine solche krise
wir hören ja immer das gesundheitssystem
ist überlastet wenn sie das vergleichen
mit deutschland hat da jetzt indien zu
wenig investiert ist man da auch auf dem
falschen fuß erwischt worden
auch schwierig zu sagen ich denke
natürlich hat man sich nicht adäquat
vorbereitet weil das ja keiner
vorhersehen konnte dass dieses ausmaß
der katastrophe so ist wie es ist aber
ich würde vorsichtig sein und mit dem
finger zu sehr auf indien zu sagen
natürlich ist hier zurzeit alles
zusammengebrochen was gesundheitssystem
jetzt wolle man schier überwältigt von
der masse der menschen und das ist das
große problem in so einem
bevölkerungsreichen land wie indien wir
haben ähnliche bilder
ich habe mich letztes jahr gesehen
berger wo im märz wir haben new york
gesehen wo kein platz in kühlhäusern
mehr waren für leisten
also das ist etwas was nicht zwingend zu
indie gelingt ist sondern ist eine
globale herausforderung der bis jetzt
noch nicht jeder entsprechenden stand
sitzen jetzt wird indien gerne immer
auch als die apotheke der welt
bezeichnet warum weil in den der größte
produzent von impfstoffen ist da müsste
man meinen mensch das ist doch klasse
und wenn man allein die zahlen liest 160
millionen impfdosen sind verteilt worden
in deutschland würde man jubeln dann
würde man sagen okay dann ist jeder
deutsche doch mal locker zweimal schon
geimpft aber wenn man das in relation
sieht mit 1,4 milliarden menschen ist
natürlich 160 millionen impfdosen ist
nicht richtig
korrekt also allein diese zahl ist
unglaublich 140 millionen in relativ
kurzer zeit aber die schiere menge der
bevölkerung hier ist natürlich enorm und
das ist das große problem und natürlich
produziert indien unheimlich viel
impfstoffe zb das indische serum
institut ist der größte impfstoff
hersteller weltweit
indien hat einen großen teil beigetragen
zu kovacs initiative ich glaube 90
prozent aller impfstoff bekommen hier
aus indien aber die produktion solcher
impfstoffe in milliarden auf lage
erfordert natürlich auch kapazitäten wie
erst aufgebaut werden müssen so dass ich
denke dass indien mittelfristig
natürlich in der lage sein wird seine
bevölkerung zu hinten aber es gab mit
sicherheit keine projektion zu einer
solchen situation und dazu muss man
sagen aktuell ist die impfstoff
verteilung wird dem nicht gerecht
also ist indien halt beim impfen noch
nicht so weit dass man sagen kann man
ist über den berg herdenimmunität etc
und nun trifft eben diese zweite welle
wir haben es im beitrag schon gesehen
sauerstoff es fehlt sauerstoff die
menschen wir haben sie im beitrag
gesehen bringen sauerstoff vom schwarz
schwarzmarkt gekauft mit in die klinik
wie geht es denn eigentlich ihnen mit
saffron tierärzte ohne grenzen wie
können sie denn helfen ich vermute ja
mal ganz einfach dass sie nicht einfach
im kleiderschrank haben und sagen hier
habe ich zehn sauerstoffflaschen die
habe ich mal vor zehn jahren hier
eingelagert
das ist völlig richtig und wir können
natürlich auch nicht als organisation
jetzt wie wir das gerne machen würde
sofort
sauerstoff konzentratoren kaufen weil
der markt leergefegt ist wie so richtig
sagten was ist ein teil unserer antwort
ist in diesem notfall dass wir natürlich
auch organisieren jetzt dass wir
sauerstoffkonzentrationen von überall
aus der welt her gekommen
wir machen das über ein 6 kanal
verteilzentren in europa das ist
angelaufen
wir kriegen unheimlich viele anfragen
von organisationen weltweit die sagen
wir schicken euch sagt uns wohin also
wir versuchen das zu koordinieren ist
ein teil ein zweiter stangen unserer
aktivitäten hier dass wir eben auch
gucken dass wir so weit es geht
sauerstoff konstruktionen in dieses land
bringen und an entsprechende
gesundheitsstrukturen verteilt wird
jetzt kommt eine frage medizinischer art
baby kanal oder kanal schreibt über
youtube warum brauchen denn auch junge
leute sauerstoff wir haben es ja nun
gesehen sauerstoff und es sind jetzt
nicht nur die alten leute die richtung
krankenhaus rennen sondern jeder
infizierte versuche ich als nicht arzt
mal darauf zu antworten
ich denke es hat damit zu tun mit dem
sauerstoffgehalt wie man im blut hat und
wenn der herr untergeht dann 40 arten
atmung und alles um die dinge die man
man braucht ist daneben sauerstoff
zuführen das hat keine es keine frage
des alters natürlich sind ältere
menschen oder schon schwache menschen
wie wir sie auch behandeln wir haben
hier einen fokus auf und so auf
risikogruppen die mit tuberkulose und
hiv infiziert sind
das sind natürlich per sicherer mensch
auch gehalten aber ist kann auch jungen
dann nochmal eine detailfrage weil sie
es ja auch beschrieben haben dass es
dieses institut gibt das eben sehr viele
impfstoffe hergestellt werden dass
indien da eigentlich ganz vorne liegt
simple medias überschreibt über youtube
oder fragt über youtube welche
impfstoffe gegen korona werden denn in
indien produziert wissen sie dass
zufällig ja die heißen hier geschieht
und corax ii und einer von denen ist in
zusammenarbeit mit
der gedanken gemacht worden und
astrazeneca
jetzt habe ich nur gelesen dass die
regierung eben gesagt hat sozusagen ein
exportstopp man hat sie haben es
beschrieben großzügig eben ein kovacs
impfstoffe abgegeben in die welt
exportiert und unter diesem exportstopp
um den eigenen land jetzt zu helfen nein
dann auch wieder ärmere staaten und die
frage ist ob eben diese exportstopp
überhaupt reicht kommen wir aber nochmal
zu ihrer arbeit welche hilfe können sie
den leisten wenn sie eben nicht hingehen
können und können sagen ja wir haben
sauerstoffgeräte wir haben sauerstoff
ampullen et cetera et cetera wie können
sie denn jetzt sozusagen den menschen da
helfen die stelle mir das irgendwie vor
der sage ich mal bayerische wald brennt
und ich stehe da mit einem eimer wasser
ist das ungefähr so die lage für sie
zumindest spiegelt dafür bisschen meine
eigene gefühlslage wieder das ist
richtig nein was wir tun können als
organisation und darauf fokussieren wir
uns jetzt gerade ist eben tatsächlich
sauerstoffzufuhr konzentrationen
einführen und verteilen in ihrem land
wir unterstützen krankenhäuser und
arbeiten zusammen mit einigen bauern
jetzt zusammenarbeit auf transit zentren
und trial strukturen damit man vor dem
krankenhaus ein bisschen sehen kann wer
muss intensiv notfall bekommen wer geht
in wer muss in einem krankenbett kommt
kann vielleicht auch ambulant barren
gewähren diese fragen versuchen wir zu
unterstützen weil wir ein bisschen
erfahrung in solchen notfällen
mitbringen und des weiteren versuch wo
wir eben auch diese erfahrung
weiterzugeben und css heute haben einige
mitarbeiter unterwegs
jetzt ist heute auch unterwegs ein
weiteres transportflugzeug der
bundeswehr ist also heute am mittwoch
vom niedersächsischen fliegerhorst
wunstorf aus mit bauteilen für eine
sauerstoff anlage nach indien gestartet
dort sollen die gerätschaften dann am
donnerstag
als teil der nothilfe für indien ein
treffen diese sauerstoff anlagen
zusammengebaut werden
es ist schon bundeswehr flieger
abgehoben es ist jetzt nicht die erste
lieferung weitere werden folgen
vor einigen tagen ist eine
lufthansa-maschine nach indien gestartet
mit britischen hilfsgütern ebenfalls um
sauerstoff zu produzieren also das zeigt
auch die zusammenarbeit zwischen den
westlichen ländern
wenn eine solche maschine unterwegs ist
sagen sie dann
das ist ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
oder ist es wirklich wichtige hilfe
nein ich sage danke danke danke für jede
hilfe die komme ich finde es ist eine
situation die erfordert solidarität
weltweit ist wie erfahren sehr viel
solidarität in das indische volk auch
und ich kann nur jedem dazu auffordern
das aufrecht zu erhalten denn alleine
kann ein land so eine situation nicht
bewältigen
also ich bin für jede für die von außen
kommt dank von ich kann nur alle bitten
das aufrecht zu erhalten sie ist gerade
angelaufen
und ich hoffe dass in den nächsten
wochen wir die massiv ausbauen können
mit wir meine ich alle menschen die hier
in dieser aufgabe seien ja und das heißt
wenn unser einer hier im fernen
deutschland sich überlegt ja was kann
ich überhaupt tun sagen sie jeder
gespendete euro hilft tatsächlich weil
man dann damit solche strukturen
schaffen kann damit sauerstoff dahin
bringen kann absolut jeder euro hilft
nur damit man sich so eine ungefähre
vorstellung machen können so ein
sauerstoff konzentrator der einen
patienten hilft er koste ungefähr 800
euro und wir werden tausende gebraucht
also zigtausend ich kann nur für jeden
euro gibt's eine verwendung das kann ich
garantieren dass es prima dass es gut zu
hören
wie sieht es nur aus mit der regierung
zum abschluss wir haben im stück von
unserem korrespondenten normen odenthal
durchaus auch kritische stimmen gehört
klar da gibt es auch eine opposition die
dem premier kritisch gegenübersteht wie
schätzen sie das ein
man hört die regierung die zentrale
regierung in neu-delhi zögert noch einen
allgemeinen lockdown zu beschließen
aus angst vor den wirtschaftlichen
folgen aber sie sind vor ort geht das
überhaupt ist die regierung zu
kritisieren oder ist das wirklich eine
sache wo man sagt da möchte man gar
nicht in deren haut stecken ja das kommt
brauchen wir die aufgaben einer
regierung befindet ich denke schon dass
sie zu kritisieren ist gleich die nicht
aus not will aber einfach aus
unterschätzung was sie gerade
angesprochen haben die politische
komponente spielt eine große rolle
was nicht nur in indien der fall ist
sondern das sieht man auch in anderen
ländern dass diverse politische ränke
eher kontraproduktiv sind in der korona
pandemie bekämpfung aber das große ding
ist hier dass die leute sich haben über
fallen lassen und diese situation das
ist das was die ausmaße wo stimmung dann
wollen wir sozusagen die daumen drücken
dass weitere hilfsflüge kommen weitere
unterstützung anrollt und sie eben nicht
mit gebundenen händen dastehen sondern
tatkräftig helfen können herrscht erst
einmal ihnen vielen vielen dank alles
gute bleiben sie gesund und sozusagen
eine erfolgreiche arbeit wenn sie den
menschen helfen wollen vielen vielen
dank nach neu delhi
ich danke schön sagen ja wir wollen
natürlich weiter reden über die
situation in indien mit jemandem er wir
haben es anfangs gesagt seit 20 jahren
da schon lebt als arzt zunächst aber
bevor wir mit andreas vogt sprechen mit
tobias fuchs sprechen von den german
doctors wollen wir einfach noch mal auf
dieses land schauen wir haben bereits
gesagt dass indien eben ein riesiges
land ist fast 1,4 milliarden menschen
die daten und fakten zu diesem land kurz
und kompakt zusammengefasst
mit fast 1,4 milliarden einwohnern ist
indien die größte demokratie der welt
aber auch ein land extreme gegensätze
indien hat die drittmeisten milliardäre
weltweit gleichzeitig leben fast 100
millionen menschen ohne strom
etwa ein viertel hat keinerlei zugang zu
toiletten und fast 15 prozent der
menschen sind unterernährt
wirtschaftlich hat indien in kürzester
zeit den sprung vom entwicklungs zum
schwellenland
geschafft und ist dabei zur ökonomischen
großmacht aufzusteigen
auch militärisch gibt sich die atommacht
selbstbewusst doch gesellschaftlich
prägt auch heute noch in vielen teilen
des landes das jahrhundertealte
hierarchische kastensystem das leben und
nicht immer profitieren die menschen vom
aufschwung indien gilt als apotheke der
welt doch die hier produzierten
medikamente und impfstoffe werden zum
großteil exportiert die folgen zeigen
sich in der korona krise besonders
dramatisch über 400.000 neue infektionen
an einem tag gemessen an der
einwohnerzahl mag das nicht viel
erscheinen doch experten gehen von einer
hohen dunkelziffer aus tobias fuchs von
den german doctors lebt seit langem in
diesem land der kontraste so kann man
das wohl sagen
seit 20 jahren arbeiten sie in einer
tuberkulose klinik in kalkutta vielen
dank dass wir mit ihnen sprechen können
beschreiben sie einfach mal die lager
sie sind ja jetzt nicht in neu delhi
soll in kalkutta ist es da ähnlich ist
es da besser was erleben sie nein in
kalkutta ist die lage nicht so
verzweifelt
es gibt auch hier viele tausend
neuerkrankungen pro tag und und es gibt
einen sehr starken druck auf das
gesundheitssystem aus aber das
gesundheitssystem ist hier nicht
kollabiert und nicht die kompensiert die
regierung lokalregierung beschlagnahmt
krankenhäuser oder bemächtigt sich
betten den kommerziellen
krankenhaussektor und und organisiert
den sauerstoff aber es ist jetzt hier
die kleine kein chaos und keine keine
keinen zusammenbruch des
gesundheitswesen links jetzt haben wir
eine user frage von xerox über youtube
wie unterscheidet sich denn die urbane
lage gegenüber der dörflichen lage
können sie was dazu sagen
sie sagen ja schon mal es ist zwischen
neu delhi und kalkutta schon ein
gewisser großer unterschied ist das so
dass auf dem land das wirklich anders
ist als in neu delhi oder mumbai
ja wir arbeiten sowohl im
innerstädtischen islams als auch hinten
abgelegenen dörfern und natürlich in der
innenstadt in den slums wo die leute
extrem dicht aufeinander lebender sind
viel mehr fälle als auf dem land wo wir
hier arbeiten da kommen
wer auf eine indische großfamilie sagen
wir mal 77 mitglieder kommen dann zehn
quadratmeter wohnraum und da können sie
keine abständen halten selbst wenn man
den leuten gesagt bitte abständen halten
das geht überhaupt nicht für die klingt
ist vielleicht sogar noch zynisch wenn
man sagt ein bisschen abständen halten
und sie können es nicht und auch das mit
dem händewaschen das ist setzt ja voraus
als die leute fließendes wasser haben
das ist aber nicht überall der fall
deswegen braucht es maske tragen leute
können sich nicht ständig jeden tag eine
neue einmal maske leisten kann sind
nicht mehr so stoff setzen diese um mund
und nase tragen weil wie effektiv ist
das denn
deswegen in diesen in diesen extremen
bevölkerungsschichten arealen da breitet
sich so eine solche natürlich viel
schneller
jetzt haben wir viel über die korona
infizierten gesprochen überfälle tote
etc
aber wir müssen ja auch mal über die
ganz anderen patienten sprechen wie
gesagt sie arbeiten seit jahren in einer
tuberkulose klinik welche folgen hat den
die pandemie für ihre patienten die nur
mit tuberkulose auf ihrer station liegen
also zunächst mal haben wir auch fälle
beim personal gab wir haben sieben fälle
beim personal zwei davon waren sehr
schwer alle haben überlebt wir haben
auch fälle auf der station gehabt mit
station muss man sich vorstellen als
einbetten saal für 20 patienten wenn da
einer oder zwei von kubik 19 bekommen
dann hat man ein problem denn die
anderen sind möglicherweise auch
infiziert und wir haben natürlich auch
in unseren ambulanzen immer wieder leute
mit husten und fieber und wissen nicht
was ist das jetzt ist es jetzt mit 19
ist es tuberkulose wir schicken die zur
testung aber es gibt halt auch sehr
viele leute in die andere krankheiten
haben als co mit 19 und die tuberkulose
patienten kamen im letzten jahr in dem
ersten harten lockdown nicht zum zuge
die lebens und behandelt weil einfach
das gesamte gesundheitssystem sich
ausgerichtet hat darauf die auf die
epidemie und die vielen kurven 19
kranken und wir haben sehr viele
patienten bereits los dann gestorben
weil sie nicht an ihre therapie
herangekommen sind was merken wir als
eine delle in unserer statistik wir
können uns denken woher diese
unsere statistik kommt und es gibt auch
zb personen die lebens
überlebensnotwendig auf bestimmte
medikamente angewiesen sind zb die
zuckerkranken auf insulin und auch die
sind gestorben in den lock down und die
sind halt auch nicht an ärzte und nicht
an ihre medikamente rangekommen deswegen
alles spricht über coby 19 uhr es gibt
hier auch sehr viele leute mit anderen
krankheiten um die hand moment sehr
massive nachteile dadurch dass sie eben
einfach keinen arzt finden oder das
krankenhaus in dem sie normalerweise
behandelt werden umfunktioniert worden
ist und dass sie eben einfach nicht an
behandlung herankommen wir haben mehrere
fragen die immer für user die immer
wieder auf den durchaus richtigen punkt
hinweisen die relativierung also gerne
eine relativierung der situation hätten
sozusagen die zahl der korona
infizierten der korona toten im
vergleich zur einwohnerzahl
wenn man das jetzt sagt 200.000 tote hat
es bisher gegeben oder 3780 tote an
einem tag dann reden wir natürlich von
hand mit 14 milliarden aber ich höre bei
ihnen jahre aus dass das sozusagen nur
die spitze des eisberges ist wenn wir
von der gesamten corona pandemie
sprechen dass man ganz andere zahlen in
relation setzen müsste nämlich auch die
toten oder die kranken von denen sie
gerade sprechen die sozusagen direkt in
diesen zahlen überhaupt gar nicht
auftauchen sondern die eben an anderen
krankheiten gestorben sind weil eben sie
überhaupt gar nicht mehr versorgt werden
können richtig ja ganz genau richtig ich
erinnere mich an eine 20 jährige frau
mit einem diabetes seit der kindheit die
regelmäßig von uns das insulin bekommen
hat muss für sie ein überlebenswichtiges
medikament ist gestorben in den ersten
lockdown es gab keinen arzt für sich es
gab kein insulin flüssig und dann
sterben eben leute ein zuckerkranker
wenn der kann ihn zu lieben bekommt er
kann binnen zehn tagen tot sein
und das ist nicht die einzige als der
locker und beendet war haben wir mal
durchgezählt was ist eigentlich aus
unseren patienten geworden und viele
fehlten dann viele von denen kommen
nicht mehr
wir haben nicht die adressen und
telefonnummer an um nachzufragen und ist
denn mit euch aber im wir verstehen
schon dass viele leute nicht mehr zu uns
gekommen sind was das zu bedeuten hat
denn das gesamte gesundheitssystem zu
sagen wir die hälfte
ausgerichtet ist oft corona und coop mit
19 dann kommen andere leute zu kurz zum
beispiel können auch nicht operiert
werden weil im ganzen krankenhaus das
personalamt mit 19 erkrankt ist oder
oder personal schon gar nicht mehr
ausreicht um den in dem betrieb
wahrzunehmen wir hätten viele leute auch
gehabt die operiert werden müssten
aber sie konnten nicht operiert werden
und das hat ihn nur diesen leuten sehr
massive nachteile eingebracht damit
haben sie herr vogt eigentlich mit sehr
bewegenden worten eine antwort gegeben
auf das was ein user über youtube
schreib legato fragt kann man die
dunkelziffer der sterbenden ungefähr
abschätzen ich entnehme ihren worten
wenn sie auf einmal patienten vermissen
aber sie nicht anrufen können dann
werden sie bestätigen können das ist der
riesige dunkelziffer ja ich kann da
leider nichts sagen da wird man oft
nachgefragt wir wissen es einfach nicht
kommen wir zu einem anderen punkt wir
haben im beitrag das eben von normen
odenthal auch schon gesehen es gibt
kritik an der regierung
wir haben auch eben besprochen hat es
fehler vielleicht gegeben
aber sie haben ja auch deutlich gemacht
man kann vielleicht nicht mit den
maßstäben die wir hier in deutschland
haben an indien rangehen denn in
deutschland gibt es beispielsweise
kurzarbeitergeld milliarden für die
wirtschaft da kann man einen lock down
oder shutdown verhängen aber beschreiben
sie doch einfach mal wie schwierig das
in indien ist denn sie haben ja in dem
land auch die erste welle miterlebt und
hamm erfahren welche sozialen folgen das
hat für leute die gar nicht von corona
infiziert worden sind aber wenn es dann
eben gegen also corona maßnahmen gibt
den lock down shut down
welche folgen hat das gehabt in der
ersten welle und wird es jetzt haben
wenn die regierung hingeht oder eine
bundesstaatliche regierung und sagt wir
machen den doktor genau in dem ersten
lockdown ebenso von märz bis mai
ungefähr drei monate da durften wir auch
wieder das haus überhaupt nicht
verlassen auch nicht als arzt und die
krankenschwestern durfte niemand das
haus verlassen die durften einfach alles
nicht arbeiten muss und das hat ganz
nebenbei sozialer verwerfungen nach sich
gezogen
wir haben zum beispiel die die familien
von tagelöhnern die sind darauf
angewiesen dass sie
täglich irgendwo einer großen baustelle
und einer großen fabrik angeheuert
werden gerade an dem tag mehrarbeit ist
damit ihr halt abends was geld mit nach
hause bringen und als die gesamten
fabriken geschlossen waren als doch die
chris planen nicht mehr fuhren ich
wusste nicht mehr und die baustellen
still lagen da hatten die auch kein
einkommen mehr und mehr gibt's dann eben
auch keine soziale hilfe kein
kurzarbeitergeld es kein sozialamt und
dann haben diese leute einfach drei
monate kein einkommen sie haben
irgendwann auch nichts mehr zu essen
gehabt das hat mich sehr beeindruckt und
nicht kennen das land ja noch aus
früheren zeiten wo
nahrungsmittelknappheit und wunder
ernährung durchaus noch da waren das
haben wir haben wir irgendwann
überwunden geglaubten ich hätte niemals
gedacht anfang 2020 was wir jetzt wieder
anfangen werden nahrungsmittelpakete an
haus zu geben an familien die nichts
mehr zu essen haben wir haben damals
tausende solcher pakete ausgegeben
werden das auch jetzt wieder tun wenn es
jetzt wieder restriktionen gibt und wir
haben auch erlebt zb bei den
wanderarbeitern die an alle versucht
haben in ihrer dörfer wieder
zurückzukommen wie viel menschliches
leid dass auch für diese familien
bedeutet hat in ein kommendes
weggefallen
der vater ist irgendwo unterwegs
zwischen die leon und kalkutta aber es
geht ja keine bahn gemacht das zu fuß
ist diese leute sind einfach in tiefe
verzweiflung geraten und ich kann das
sehr gut verstehen dass die politiker
hier sehr genau abwägen brauchen wir
jetzt diesen blog don ganz wirklich oder
kann man zu einem halben lockdown machen
denn die erfahrungen des ersten lok
downs waren sehr schwierig
psychosozialen folgen
bezüglich der epidemie war das natürlich
nützlich aber das muss halt
gegeneinander abgewogen werden
also wenn eine stadt jetzt wie kalkutta
hingeht und sagt busse und bahnen fahren
einfach nicht mehr weil die zu dicht
gepackt sind natürlich würde man sagen
tolle maßnahme gute maßnahme so muss man
kroner bekämpfen
aber es hat ganz andere folgen gerade
heute hat sich die landesregierung die s
bahnen und busse gestoppt wird also
jetzt nichts mehr wenn man sich morgens
wahnsinn s bahnhof stellt da sieht man
wie viele massen an leuten auf form von
der land vom land aus in die stadt
pendeln morgens freien und abends zurück
und die sind auch auf diese s bahn
angewiesen haben natürlich kein auto
besitzt ja niemanden privates auto diese
wenn diese s bahnen nicht mehr fahren
und die busse nicht das sind auch keine
strecken die man mit fahrradfahren kann
dann selbst für die das einkommen direkt
und die haben auch keinerlei soziale
sicherung in dem moment also allein
dieser maßnahme jetzt hier die s-bahn
und zu stoppen die bus sitzen stoppen
und geschäfte dürfen nur noch
stundenweise am tag drauf haben das wird
sehr viele zehntausende familien bieter
zu stehen kommen die einfach kein
einkommen mehr handel
damit haben sie eine antwort geben auf
die frage von jens hauptmann der über
facebook gefragt hat wäre an der stelle
nicht ein kompletter ein totaler locker
und die richtige idee vielleicht
versehen mit einer notbremse analog der
beispielgebende politik der deutschen
bundesregierung sie haben sehr deutlich
gemacht dass das alles etwas diffiziler
ist eben in indien wo die strukturen
eben anders sind und es nicht diese
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
absicherungen gibt nun mal in dem
zusammenhang auch um mal die
unterschiede deutlich zu machen
juni fragt über facebook kann sich dort
denn jeder eine behandlung überhaupt
erlauben um auch mal zu sagen bei uns
sagt dir sicherlich krankenkasse zahlt
als wenn ich ins krankenhaus gehe aber
wie wie sind denn die situation da
überhaupt nur die staatlichen
krankenhäuser verlangen den patienten
nichts ab wenn die mit cupid 19 kommen
die verkommenen wert zugewiesen bekommen
medikamente und sauerstoff das müssen
sie nicht bezahlen
allerdings sind die krankenhäuser alle
voll und die regierung beschlagnahmt
andere häuser die er gar nicht gehören
und fragt im kommerziellen
krankenhaussektor nach ob sie da betten
belegen dürften die bezahlen das dann
auch es geht gar nicht so sehr darum
dass es das zu den leuten das nicht und
zahlt würde es einfach die betten sind
einfach zu wenig und ärzte und
krankenschwestern sind zu wenig sind
weil ich auch infizierte noch viele
indische ärzte gestorben einfach an co
at 19 und viele krankenschwestern und
dann gibt es halt ein engpass sittlich
nicht daran darin dass wir diese
medikamente die leute brauchen und den
sauerstoff nicht bezahlen könnten
sondern es gibt ein strukturelles
problem
dann haben wir noch eine frage von
paradoxon über youtube wird deutschland
endlich impfdosen an indien verschicken
und nicht nur die notwendigen
hilfsmittel und kranke zu versorgen
sollte man nicht dafür sorgen dass die
bevölkerung gesund wird ja ich bin ja
kein politiker auch was deutschland
jetzt an indien schickt das kann ich
nicht so gemacht haben
wir arbeiten auf einer ganz ganz
einfacheren ebene ich sehe jeden tag so
40 50 personen die sich mit allem
möglichen bei uns vorstellen da ist
tuberkulose reisten gebrochener knochen
sei es eine bluthochdruck oder ein
schlaganfall sie kommen als zu uns wir
müssen für die versuchen das beste
daraus zu machen und dazu gehört zum
beispiel auch die ältere und die
chronisch kranke bevölkerung
aufzufordern sich impfen zu lassen
das sehen nicht alle 1 und 4 sind nicht
informiert und viele scheuen sich im
haus muss man den leuten sagen ich bin
auch schon zweimal gegen worden und ich
fühle mich besser damit und die
krankenschwestern sagen dann auch ja
denn du alles schon zweimal gegen wir
müssen jetzt auch ihr zucker ist ein
risiko für sie oder ihr asthma ist ein
risiko das sie also auf dieser ebene
versuchen wir die leute auch zu
mobilisieren was sie zur impfung gehen
ich kann es nicht so über die großen
lieferungen aus deutschland reden wir
haben eine ganz andere ebene auf der wir
arbeiten kriegen sie denn sagen sie was
zu german doctors kriegen sie denn jetzt
ich sag mal verstärkung von kollegen aus
deutschland
geht das überhaupt das einen doktor mal
eben nach indien fliegt und sagt jetzt
krempelt die ärmel hoch und helfe ihnen
stichwort visum oder sind sie am ende
jemand der seit 20 jahren auch ein
bisschen oder in den letzten jahren
allein auf weiter flur kämpft wir waren
bis zum beginn der epidemie zu sechs
deutschen ärzten fünf davon waren kurze
zeit ins tun sind die also sechs wochen
dienst getan haben den staffelstab land
an die nächsten deutschen herz zu
überreicht haben und ich war der einzige
langzeit hinterzimmer seit dem märz gibt
es keinerlei wiese visa mehr von der
indischen regierung also es gibt
genügend deutsche ärzte die sich hier
einbringen möchten gerne aktiv sein
möchten aber sie bekommen kein visum und
es ist auch wirklich riskant für sie
deutschen erz und das hat auch seinen
grund dass indien keine visa natürlich
wollen wir nicht noch andere corona
mutanten ins land bekommen aber die
wollen eben auch nicht dass leute die
auch touristen visum
dann hier zu schaden kommen oder
möglicherweise noch sterben das wollen
wir natürlich verhindern und deswegen
kommen im moment keine anderen deutschen
ärzte ins land rein ich hoffe dass das
irgendwann wieder so weit sein wird
dann drücken wir in dieser hinsicht auf
jeden fall die daumen wünschen ihnen die
energie dieser arbeit weiterzumachen
wir danken ganz herzlich für diese
bereinigungen seinen schilderungen
drücken wirklich einfach die daumen und
haben durch sie beide sehr gute
einblicke bekommen und glaube ich
verstanden wie wichtig hilfe für indien
ist egal in welcher form und sei es eben
auch ein bisschen das daumendrücken und
die anerkennung vielen vielen dank
jetzt haben wir über die arbeit der
german doctors gesprochen wir haben über
die arbeit der ärzte ohne grenzen
gesprochen nur zwei organisationen und
nur unsere gesprächspartner nur zwei
deutsche die versuchen in indien alles
menschenmögliche zu tun um den menschen
dort zu helfen wenn sie jetzt hingehen
und sagen ich würde auch gerne helfen
ich finde das beeindruckend was kann ich
tun
man kann ja nicht einfach mal eben
hinfliegen und die ärmel hoch krempeln
sie können aber etwas tun nämlich
spenden zum beispiel an das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe das hat
ein spendenkonto eingerichtet mit dem
stichwort zdf corona hilfe weltweit mit
der iba nummer de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 weiter informationen finden sie
natürlich bei uns im internet unter
spenden punkt zdf.de das soweit die
informationen dass auch sie etwas machen
können ich danke ganz herzlich für ihr
interesse
sage tschüss bis bald und auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]